hey everyone it's michos from order
flows.com and this is the orderflows
market analysis for Thursday May 18 2017
a very interesting day yesterday it's
been very interesting week extremely
volatile week um we did recover from
Wednesday's big sell off and you know
there's just a lot of things happening
in the markets and orderflow I I think
you know would give you an an edge um
it's not going to pick every single
turning point in the market but it picks
some really nice turning points and
before I jump in um got to go through
the brief disclaimer this presentation
is for educational and informational
purposes only it should not be
considered a solicitation to buy or sell
a Futures Contract or Mak any other type
of investment decision Futures Trading
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading only those with sufficient risk
Capital should consider trading past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results
tools I use in this presentation are the
orderflows trader software which is the
volume footprint chart and the Delta
scalper and like I said you know very uh
very interesting week in the equity
markets and in the currency markets so
I'll start with the um the 10
range 10 range e- mini chart now you
know normally I trade with a I keep a
four range chart and a 10 range chart
open I'm not a big fan of minute charts
the reason being you know the market
moves based on price and value it
doesn't move based on time increments
doesn't the the market doesn't have a
clock that says oh it's 5 minutes has
elapsed I should start forming a new bar
rather I I use range bars because I like
to see how price moves and you know how
it
reacts as it's moving rather than oh you
know we're just trading here oh it's
time to start a new bar because it's uh
110 or you know it's time to start a new
bar because 60 seconds just elapsed um
you know to me that doesn't really give
a accurate representation of the
market so that said um in the morning um
or I'll start at around 7 there was this
buying okay we around 7:00 you know we
had been
trading around 2347 okay 2350 that area
you know in here somewhere
the this is the Delta scop or given a
sell it's a little bit you know it's a
little move um but you know really
things really took off when cash opened
at 8:30 just before Cash open you do
have the stack buying in Balance okay
but 8:30 you know things are definitely
going to change and you're going to get
a lot of volume coming in and I was
really looking to see what the market
was going to do okay and cash open a
8:30 we started moving higher okay then
we know just started going sideways here
over the next uh
you know basically the next what time is
that about you know 8:30 the next 40 30
minutes more or less you do have another
stack buying and balance in here okay
which is good you're starting to see
buying come in okay before you had
selling but you're just going sideways
right you're getting you know a couple
positive Deltas some negative Deltas me
you could read what you want into this
it's a little bit declining but you know
the market is just kind of spinning its
wheels at this point all of a sudden you
get some aggressive buying coming in
here and you start ring okay that's a
good sign um you know you got the buying
and balance you got more buying and
balances in the next bar that's a sign
this Market is going to go up and you
got some nice increasing Delta here 949
1200 3,900 6422 now I was saying in the
room at this time I
saying you know for a move to be
happening you know what you're going to
want to see is increased buying come in
and how you're going to see it is you
know watch these Deltas there should be
closing you know if if a move is strong
right we should be closing the Delta the
final Delta number relatively close to
the max Delta number that's going to
tell me that it's just dominated by
buying you know we're closing almost on
our highs of delta in the bar so you got
this bar
949 the max Delta was 988 that's very
close 1266 we closed at 1218 3914 we
closed right on 3914 6473 we closed at
6422 but you know even in this bar here
by 3914 I'm already convinced
okay and what happens is we just shoot
we shoot higher we start shooting higher
um we get up to this point up here
2366 and I'm starting to wonder you know
hey are we going to take out this high
or not you know we got all Rising point
of controls at this point and you don't
have you know any reason to be getting
short in this move up at all I mean you
do have a small Delta here minus 146 you
know but the bar is still it's still
green you know why do you have a
negative Delta because you got a lot of
volume here people are selling into
these bids you know this is supportive
volume on the way up you get up here up
here near this high high of day again I
was curious to see if we're going to get
there I thought it was a little bit
optimistic to get there a bit early but
we did nevertheless and what do you got
up here you have a Divergence okay but
you start seeing you know the Delta
changing you got -400 - 4,9
8982 you got 512 here still negative but
the bar is green okay so you know I'm
starting to wonder what's really going
on you know I we seeing some B come back
in off this high or not and what happens
we just you know we started getting some
small Deltas 295 580 so again you know
to me when I start seeing small Deltas
I'm starting to think you know we found
a level where you know where trade is
occurring you know without moving the
market and then we start dominating by
sellers you got a lot of imbalances in
here 3,000 2,
1800 and we start to sell off we come
down here we get these double bars
double point of control is at the same
level positive Delta small positive
Delta big positive Delta bigger positive
Delta again you know not reading too
much into this you know to me this is
just the market trading you know I'm not
saying oh yeah you know price rejector
gave this high this low here even though
it did you know I'm I'm still not
convinced you know the market is very
volatile and it can turn on you on a
dime I'm really not convinced and we
just go sideways in here you know we're
getting alternating bars red green red
green red
green and you we're going sideways okay
now this is why I like you using the
Delta because Delta is going to clue me
in on a move that's possibly about to
happen and we get to this bar here and
the Delta scalper signals me that hey
you know
what the according to the delta or the
bars most recent bars and the way the
price action's been get ready for a
possible move and you know we're trading
2362 and then what happens Market just
explodes to the upside we go all the way
up new highs new highs all the way up to
71 no reason really to sell up here you
do have a Divergence but that's it um we
make some new highs up here at 142 so we
go from all the you know from 62 all the
way up to
75 that's a 13-point move in the snps um
you know if you only take one trade a
day on one lot that makes your day right
there you know granted you don't every
day you don't have 13-point moves like
that you know sometimes it's a
three-point move that you get yet but
you know the way this Market's been
crazy the last uh the last
week there's been some very nice
opportunities so anyway we get up to
this High here and to me this was very
interesting um you know I I was doing my
presentation at this time and I sort of
keeping one eye on the charts you know
while I'm doing this and I just remember
seeing this bar here now you do have a
Delta scalper given a sell here but this
bar here to me was very enticing why he
had very strong positive Delta 7,000
which is strong you very very strong and
what did Delta do ended up at 303 didn't
get the negative Delta but it ended up
at 303 so it was up
7,000 went from 0 to plus 7,000 down to
to 300 so it swung back you know it
swung back s you know basically
7,400 more sellers and buyers in this
bar and then the Delta scalper picks up
that hey you know possible short entry
here and the market just you know it
sells off again down to the the low 60s
um you do have the stack buying in
Balance
here but again um you know it's it's one
of those things you know you make the
decision do you get out at this point or
are you going to let see what's going to
happen um in the next bar you know we we
have the stack buying and balance and we
just came right down through it pretty
quickly in the next uh 5 minutes and you
know I said you know went lower then you
know continued on Lower into the close
um um on the reopen you do have Delta
scalper gave a buy but it's a red bar so
you shouldn't be you know that
interested in it and on the low of the
night session you do have the price
rejector given a uh a buy there now like
I said you know a lot of interesting
things in the markets yesterday and I
mean I could really talk for an hour
about all the stuff that was happening
but um you know I'm just going to try
and show you some of the what I think
were the highlights
here um this was crude oil this was was
5: in the morning you get down to this
level down here this low of the day
4805 point of control right on the
bottom you got a ratio bounds low and
you got very strong volume you know for
5: in the morning you got 139 120 400 so
you're looking at um you know what is
that about uh close to 700 Lots being
traded down here on the low and you know
so why do I like it because orderflow is
telling me that there's volume down here
that's supporting this Market that's
stopping this move and we get a nice
move up from you know the next bar here
at 48 whatever this is 486 all the way
up up up um oops you know we just you
know go all the way up to the you know
up to the 60s again I'm not saying you
you'd sell up here but you know you
should have at least been able to catch
um at least 20 cents out of that
move and yeah let's talk about the
currencies really quick
oh I talk about beans first beans were
very interesting um kind of similar
actually and we had hit this
level this morning early in this I say
early in the session but you know after
the 8:30 reopen in the beans we got down
to this level 950 and you you talk about
Traders being trapped but what you had
is you had very good buyer down here you
can see at this time at at 852 he traded
1,700 59 contracts there at that low you
had a lot of people selling into this
low trying to break it and see if they
could trigger stops below this you know
950 not only is it you know more of a I
say a longer term level but you know
it's also a psychological level um in
the
soybeans whoops sorry um give me a sec
here clicked on something that that's
the the bean chart but um I just want to
talk about this you know this was to me
this is very interesting you know people
talk about Traders being trapped so you
got all these people selling the [__]
out of this trying to get this Market to
go lower all of a sudden they realize
they can't we start ticking higher tick
tick tick higher so all these people
that were selling this looking for the
market to break out and go lower they
got to start covering it here we trade
from
950 you know all the way you just sort
of go sideways we get all the way up to
like 956 later um you know we do rally
up here you know along the way you got
the
the you've got the
uh Delta scalper given this buy here
then you got the Delta scalper given a
sell here we do sort of drift around
lower lower lower and again then we test
this level again at 950 you still got
volume there and you know people are
really trying to get this Market to move
through it you know even on the way down
there is still supportive volume here
1100 1100 which for the beans is a lot
but we get down to this level again I'm
very curious to see what's going to
happen when we get down there you know
are we going to bounce again are we
going to violate it if we if we violate
it then you know watch out okay I
mean we could trigger stops and go lower
and what happens boom you get through
it and very quickly you drop another you
get from 950 you drop all the way down
to 946 you got the stack sellum balance
so you know I do believe stops were
triggered here we get this big push
lower um you know over the next two or
three minutes we hit this level down
here is a doy bar but you know point of
control at the bottom and again you got
very decent volume there bounce up a
little bit selling comes in again you
know you're not seeing at this point you
know very heavy volume that we were
seeing up here just above 950 950 and a
half you know thousands on the
bid you come through these levels again
and and you get more selling you know
aggressive selling coming into these
lows boom boom boom boom here you got
some decent volume
and you just go lower you know so you
know even though you have you know the
supportive volume there you know this
1700 you know you got a couple things
one you know the short-term Traders the
people that are trying to break out this
move you know to get it to go lower
they're stuck they got to cover it back
up here because they can't get it lower
and it's starting to go against them you
know the the the scalpers the day
Traders everyone that was trying to get
it lower could it then when some bigger
money came into the market some stronger
money stronger hands to push it down
again gets it through 1100 gets it
through another 1100 starts coming down
in here they're just pounding the heck
out of it and boom they finally get it
through and you know sort of the Dam
breaks and you get this pretty quick
move um you know another three cents and
later another um two or three cents as
well what was the other Market I want to
talk about here finally just getting
over this
cold still got a stuffed up nose
though um British pound talk about
really quick
now here it
is again this is
yesterday so in the morning you we
started you did have I believe it was
retail um I think it was retail sales
yesterday I don't know so so much news
is coming off fast and I say Fast and
Furious but you know it's coming out and
you everything's just happened it seems
like a whirlwind honestly with
everything coming out and I believe it
was retail sales came out yesterday in
the UK at 3:30 Chicago time and they
were very strong so you know British
pound got a rally you got Divergence it
fails it rallies back up you get um
another Divergence and you get this
Divergence with the ratio and again I
always talk about getting using
something extra in the order
flow to make the trade you know to take
the symbol if you're just taking
Divergence by itself yeah it can work it
cannot work but you know when you add
ratios into it which you know comes with
my software then you know that's why I
put it in the software you know because
before what I used to do is I'd hit a
high I'd start looking at the order flow
do this calculation either you know in
my head sometimes I can do it in my
head or do it on a calculator you know
if I thought it was borderline but you
know that's why I have these ratios
printing up here to just tell me you
know hey there's price rejection up here
13059 and what happens you go from 13059
you just sell off you know the I'll say
the rest of the morning you know but you
have a nice sell off from you know 59
down to you know 10 that area eventually
you go lower but you know that was you
know
that's that's you know I W say the
beauty of orderflow but you know when
you're using
orderflow you should just you be looking
at a lot of different things and you
know
it looks like a lot of different things
but you know there's tools that you
could use that make it a lot easier for
you to make decisions you know I mean
yeah you don't need ratios on your
footprint chart you know I said I put it
there for my convenience you know then
people started you know I was talking to
other Traders said hey yeah you know can
give me a copy of software well you know
I can't you I got to sell it to you um
you know that's how I got into it but
uh you know and that's why I use the
ratios it's for my own trading you know
I don't put it out there because hey I
want to get people using this no I I
developed it initially for my own
trading and you know people were seeing
what I was doing and then they started
asking you know how can I get it and
then you just sort of exploded from
there now bonds Bonds were kind of
difficult this morning in all honesty um
there was this High though at 5:00 point
of control right at the top of the bar
you have a ratio you don't have a a
Divergence but it's very close it's 50
is the Delta
now you know I know people are are
sticklers for exactness it has to be
exact but you know with a good Trader
can you know sort of make a decision and
and override the trading system now if
you have a reason to get short here and
you do you have a ratio you have a point
of control at the top well if you got a
small Delta and again you know for me
you know something in the 50s and below
is small this is 58 well people say you
said 50 you know this is 58 yeah it's
still around that level which I consider
neutral I mean it might it could you
know difference of one trade could
easily turn it negative and then you'd
have that Divergence okay and you know
dealing with the range chart sometimes
there's just not enough volume in the
bar as it starts selling off that
there's going to be enough volume to
turn the Delta negative to get you know
the so you could have a Divergence so
this is you know one of those borderline
divergences and again you know 58 Lots
in the bonds is a difference of one
trade I know people that regularly trade
Bonds in 100 lot Clips okay so you know
if there was volume here and then they
sold it you know it'd be a negative
Delta and you'd have the Divergence so
again you know this is a borderline
trade but again I like that point of
control is at the top and I like that
you do have a ratio again if it was a
swing high I would still like it you
know but at the high of the day you know
we're sort of trained to be looking for
divergences also but I still you know I
said you know if a swing High with the
point of control at the top in a ratio I
would still action on it so even though
it's at the high of day you don't have a
Divergence I'd still action on it and we
sell
off we come down here uh
642 you've got the U-turn you know
indicating a buy you've got the single
print you got a ratio um you do get a
little bit of a move but you just mostly
go sideways for uh most of the morning
then you get the Delta scalper given a
sell here at 9:00 it sells off to the
price rejection
but just goes sideways after that we
hanging around this yellow line is the
opening price for the
session and you know we don't really go
anywhere um you know for most of the
session we just sort of hang around that
line when you start hanging around the
opening price to me that's a market that
has no Direction that's just sort of
rotating around value because once we
start rotating around the opening price
generally your point of control and it's
going to be around your value area
anyway um
Japanese
Yen I didn't talk I talked about the
pound I didn't talk about the Yen Pon
chiwa but this was interesting this
morning okay now one of the things my
software does you know my software is
designed to highlight things to me okay
that you know if you've ever traded for
prolonged periods of times you do lose
your concentration okay
and when I
was talking to my programmer to create
the order flows Trader software I wanted
to had them put in things that I
normally look for but I sometimes
Overlook because you know if I'm looking
at different markets you know I've got
you know six eight markets going on at
once you know you just got to be
scanning right you're just scanning and
I wanted to highlight things and one of
the things I wanted them to highlight to
me was the single prints in a bar
you know like on the Red Bar that's what
these um boxes are and it is important
to me because it's also a sign of price
rejection
and we came up to the swing High you got
a ratio bounds low then you get two
single prints this one's a ratio this
one's not a ratio but it's still a
single
print and it's telling me there's price
rejection up here okay you got buying
imbalances you know just right off this
top so I know there was people trying to
come up and buy it to move it higher you
know 44 here 40 they couldn't get it
higher and you just buying just dries up
you know one lot trades four lot trade
and then what happens we can't get past
this level the market you know you just
seeing you know buying you can only get
it up one or two price levels and then
the buying just dries up there's nobody
lifting the offer anymore you know one
lot four lot we start working our way
down you know 90
73 all the way down into the 50s the 40s
lower um Delta surge given a sell there
um yeah you just you just keep going
lower and lower and
lower but you know again just to
highlight you know the importance of
single prints okay now you don't need my
software to look at single prints you if
you having a footprint chart you can see
it with your own eyes but you know I
like to have things visual I'm a visual
person right Instagram I love you know
it's a lot of pictures I don't need to
read stories like on Facebook you know
people like to write long post I like to
look at pictures I'm a visual person I I
think the brain processes visual things
a lot faster than um you know words
and looking at numbers you know similar
to words you know I want to be
highlighted to certain things now that's
why um you know we put the Box you know
it's it's a green box around a single
print on a green candle a red box around
the uh single print on a red bar again
it's on the bottom of a up Candle on the
bid side side it's on the upper side of
a red Candle on the top and it is
important because you know Watch What
Happens you I always say you know people
say well how do you define how do you
what's your levels that you trade around
well you know price action you look for
swing highs or swing lows okay and how
do you determine if it's a swing low
well there there are ways but the simple
ways you see well okay we have a swing
High here we're trading down here is
this a swing low probably not is this a
swing low probably why because we have a
single print here so you see this Market
goes from you know this single print
what do we do we rally we go all the way
up to this you know this is your first
Red Bar on this move from 30 all the way
up to 60 and you your first Red Bar you
get a single print up here and what
happens the market sells off
again again I'm not so interested in
bars in the middle of moves I I am at
certain times you know it it just helps
me you know confirm to me that this
Market is going lower
and what happens we get down here to
this one green bar the market rallies
again you got a single print there so
you know what happens we went from
single print you rally all the way up to
a single print you sell off to a single
print you rally to a single
print um you got a swing low here no
single print okay it's close it's the
ratio almost it's 7 it's not blue
because I use 699 actually um if I had
it at 7 you know it would give me a a
signal you got point of control the
bottom um you know just sort of rally
up start coming down I do like this bar
here point of control at the bottom but
you know just you got price rejection up
here you know the bar previous you got a
single print then this bar you got the
single print
but you know it's you know then you get
down here to this swing low what happens
you got a single print you know so watch
when you get to potential swing lows or
swing highs and you start seeing you
know you have a move down all of a
sudden you got a green bar hey watch
what's what's going to happen on here
you're going to get a single print or
not if you are it it can be quite
powerful you rally up here you don't
have a single print um you start coming
off you get down here is this a swing
low I don't know we're sort of going
sideways in here um you know we sell off
again you get down here single print
just sort of go sideways another single
print you do pop up a little bit before
you sell off um you know nothing down
there you get up here single print you
come back
off you know so why watch it you know
when you hit
potential you know and this is only you
know the first couple hours of the
morning um I don't want to go through
the whole day on every single contract
but you sort of get the idea again you
know if you're using a footprint chart
you don't need my software to highlight
that to you but honestly if you're
watching many different markets it it's
there to help you right help you in your
um analysis right that's that's really
what you you want you know as as a
Trader you want tools that are going to
help you U make decisions faster you
know cuz unfortunately it is a it is a
game of speed nowadays okay what am I
looking at that's soy beans um talk
about uh where's
the what I want to talk about uh what
was the next
one I think it was buns let me just find
my bun shart here
ones here it
is uh where am I
here okay so
buns um what do I really want to get
interested in this Market here um you
know we do have these fail
divergences go keep going higher higher
higher more fail
divergences you get up here you have a
single print you do have a ratio but
again no
Divergence um you get up here up here
you know ratio ratio no Divergence still
got all the positive Delta just sort of
go sideways again you take out the
high Delta scalper you know right off
the high on the red bar now again you
had Delta scalper here but it's a green
bar I'm not interested in taking it
there in a green bar I'm interested in
in getting confirmation from the bar
that it's you know going in the
direction that I like so you you hit
your high you your high bar you got very
you got basically a neutral Delta of
Seven nextx bar Delta scalper kicks
in more continued selling very strong
1,400 900 2,000 negative Delta and you
know we go lower we get down to this bar
here where you got the Delta scalp we
giving you a buy you do have point of
control right at the bottom you do have
a ratio as well and you rally you rally
up um close to the high actually you got
the Stacked in Balance Market doesn't
sell off it just goes sideways you get a
bullish signal right here actually after
this bearish signal which is a sign
that's probably not going to work out
Delta scalper given the sell here and
you know we just sort of work our way
lower you do get some strong selling
coming in here now
you get this this is the three in a row
right here one two three you do get the
pull back here um it's between these two
pointed controls to get short but you
don't get that move you do get the
negative bearish bar here with the ratio
and the single print but it just goes
sideways on you over the next the next
bar and then this bar then when it gets
up here it's really it's pushing your
stop which is going to be right up here
where this point of control is in the
initial bar the worst case scenario stop
would be behind this 10 Lots here but
really the when you start trading up
towards this point of control in the
first bar that's your your trigger to
look to get out so that one you know
that three in a row didn't work out
Delta scalper given a sell there
actually but it's a green bar again you
know that's not where you want to be
taking them you want to take sells on
red bars like this one here um you know
that's why it's it's going to be more
effective you know why get short when
the price action of the bar doesn't even
confirm um the reason you know the the
the sell you know why get long when the
bars can't even close higher when it
opened you know again it's reason why I
didn't add that in there into the the
program
is or the indicator whatever you want to
call it is because you know I I want
people to still you know make the final
decision in their
trading you know I want them to
understand read the order flow and and
make a decision based on that so you
know this is a nice sell you know 16186
six we get all the way down into the 60s
um Delta scalper gives a buy
here it just goes sideways on
you that one wouldn't that one would
have stopped you out um you know we're
coming into 10:00 which is the you know
the cash close in Europe for the
bonds for the
Buns
so that's it actually I mean you know
again I could I could talk about a lot
of different uh know some of these other
markets but um I'm trying to keep these
recordings to about a half hour so
thanks for watching this um to learn
more about order flows visit my website
orderflows
docomo to Delta scalper if you're
interested in the Delta scalper I'll
probably take it off the market again
because
um I I I've I've got this thing that I'm
working on which you know it's for the
Inner Circle so you know for the people
that really want to I I don't want to
get into the indicator selling I'd
rather get into dealing more with people
interested in orderflow so you know I
have my inner circle I'm going to be
opening it up
for um for membership again and you know
Delta scalper will be know one of the
benefits of joining if you already have
the Delta scalper um let me know but
you'll get you know maybe a different
you'll get access to other indicators
that I got as well in the uh Inner
Circle so you know if you're interested
in learning more about the Inner Circle
just message me if you're already on my
distribution list uh you be getting an
email over the
weekend and you know it's really takes
my inner circle really takes orderflow
you know to the next level I've already
got about 35 videos I've recorded and I
I hope to get it up to I've got another
five that I just have to record actually
um you know but they deal with things as
double tops double bottoms rounding tops
rounding bottoms trade management time
framing PLC migration um
you know
references and and there's a couple
others but um you I hope to get those
recorded actually tonight so you know
thanks for watching this video and you
know again if you're interested in the
Inner Circle just message me it's uh
it's not open to the public yet but it
will be open to the public uh over the
weekend so thanks everyone bye-bye